it was an ominous sight
but it wasn't entirely unexpected
elite russian soldiers creeping into
harkeev's northern suburbs
the city is an obvious target the
russian borders only 20 miles away
but the people who live here do not want
an occupying force
in a series of videos verified by sky
news we see soldiers who we believe to
be ukrainian
they engage an enemy column
with machine guns and rocket-propelled
grenades
this is intense close combat
is everyone okay shouts one man
then we see a column of badly damaged
vehicles being searched by ukrainian
troops
they're armored four by fours with
russian markings and they have been
peppered with bullets
the occupants are nowhere to be seen
a pretty pretty intense day today we
spoke to a local resident who took
shelter as the battle raged close by
people from the different uh districts
of the cities they saw the groups of
three four uh vehicles and some kind
some people
we have
quite strong
defense here in in the city and we have
the special troops
who are who can
make the who can have the battle inside
the city it's a different story than
outside
this city of 1.5 million has experienced
three days of warfare and many have had
to move underground
the city's children's hospital has done
the same the patients and their parents
now trying to cope in the cold in this
rudimentary shelter
we're living here now this is our house
said one mother
tens of thousands have left her kiev
seeking shelter in other communities
like the city of dinipro to the south
there is food and beds for people like
anatoly who had to leave his elderly
parents behind
how did you feel when you left the city
were you feeling scared were you feeling
frightened
foreign that's a question they'll ask to
the north in sumi where a residential
complex was hit by artillery shells
at least six people were killed
including a seven-year-old girl
in harkev the local authorities say they
are back in control the russian
incursion has been repulsed
it seems the nation's second largest
city will not submit
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine